selon lé haut à metz 8 à 10% de la
population mondiale est atteint de
dyslexie un trouble d'apprentissage qui
se manifeste à part des difficultés de
lecture de prononciation mais aussi
d'attention pour en parler julia siggers
nous a rejoint bonjour julia est ce que
l'on sait expliquer la dyslexie alors
d'abord il faut comprendre que c'est un
trouble qui fait partie d'une plus
grande famille de troubles que l'on
appelle disent vous avez la dysphasie la
dysorthographie la dyspraxie la
dysgraphie on va pas rentrer dans les
détails mais ce qui est ce qu'ils ont en
commun c'est que les modifie la capacité
non seulement à retenir à comprendre à
récupérer mais aussi à transmettre
l'information est pour l'instant et bien
les causes sont encore assez méconnue
les scientifiques pourtant ont l'air de
s'accorder sur le fait que ce serait un
problème de fonctionnement du cerveau ou
en tout cas un cerveau qui
fonctionnerait différemment et ce n'est
en rien un problème d'intelligence voire
de manque de stimulation bien au
contraire les personnes peut être les
plus grands de ce monde était dyslexique
pour en citer que deux einstein ou
léonard de vinci donc voilà c'est
vraiment pas un problème de
d'intelligence alors commence à se
manifester bien tout simplement les
enfants présentent qui présente une
dyslexie vont avoir la difficulté à
décoder déjà les mots qu'ils vont lire
en lisant il vaut oublier parfois des
lettres ils vont inverser ou remplacés
par exemple sans faire exprès ce qui va
affecter bien sûr la vitesse la
précision de leurs lectures alors
contrairement à la croyance populaire
tous les enfants dyslexiques ne
n'inverse pas forcément les lettres et
ne confondent pas forcément le bep ou le
paie et le qi même si certains
évidemment le fond alors pour vous
donner quelques exemples concrets
l'enfant va par exemple oublié il va par
exemple ajouter ou inverser des sons
dans le même mot
il va par exemple dire tab au lieu de
table ou encore il va confondre des mots
qui sont très semblables comme par
exemple m ou amis en plus il va avoir
aussi de la difficulté à reconnaître
rapidement des mots qui l'aura vu par le
passé mais que l'on ne peut pas
déchiffrer lettre par lettre je donne un
exemple s'il a lu par le passé monsieur
est bien malgré tout il va le lire comme
étant monsieur heures alors il faut
savoir aussi que la dyslexie a priori
selon certains certaines études serait
héréditaire 5 ans les enfants ont 50%
plus de chances des dyslexiques si l'un
des deux parents est dyslexique ou
présentent un trouble de langage alors
comment justement diagnostiquer la
dyslexie julien alors c'est un
diagnostic rapide comme pour toutes tout
trouble évidemment elle est est
important c'est une orthophoniste qui va
qui va s'occuper justement de poser le
diagnostic souvent le diagnostic pas
l'enfant avant qu'il commença à lire et
écrire et même pas avant le ce1 ou le
ce2 et il y à certains signes qui
peuvent mettre la puce à l'oreille un
petit peu plus tôt dans la jeunesse
comme par exemple des enfants qui
n'aiment pas jouer avec les laissant les
rimes les comptines ou inventer des
nouveaux mots ce peut être aussi des
enfants qui n'ont pas ou peu d'intérêt
pour les livres et les histoires en tout
cas quand c'est eux qui doivent lire a
par contre il adore écouter les
histoires ou alors des difficultés par
exemple à dire certains mots compliqués
aéroports toboggan ou encore accordéon
alors une découverte faite par des
chercheurs français a permis en tout cas
de mieux comprendre ce trouble
absolument deux physiciens français
albert le floch et guy repart ou en
effet découvert qu'à l' inverse des noms
dyslexique et bien les dyslexiques avait
deux yeux directeur ce qui provoque ce
que l'on appelle des images miroir je
vous l'expliquais dans un instant et ça
crée une superposition des images en
fait ils se sont intéressés à ce qu'on
appelle les centraux id de maxwell ce
sont en fait des tâches que vous avez
dans les yeux et qui reçoivent la
lumière et qui sont aussi responsables
de la perception des détails et bien
tout simplement chez les personnes non
dyslexiques les centraux id n'ont pas la
même forme vous voyez ici ils sont
asymétriques ce qui fait que vous pouvez
avoir soit la dominance d'un oeil droit
soit la dominance d'un oeil gauche ce
que ça comme conséquence le fait d'avoir
cette asymétrie c'est que ça permet de
gommer ce que l'on appelle l'image
miroir donc si vous une dominance oeil
droit votre ca va effacer cette image
miroir et donc vous allez voir très
clairement cette lettre pareil si vous
êtes dominant oeil gauche le problème
avec les personnes dyslexiques a priori
selon cette étude c'est que en fait
elles ont exactement la même forme donc
les deux oeil se retrouvent domino et
donc l'effet miroir ne s'efface pas ce
qui fait que la personne peut voir une
espèce de super position pour pallier ce
problème justement une lampe a été créée
vous l'avez apporter voilà exactement ça
s'appelle lily for life c'est une langue
qui peut être utilisé autant pour les
enfants que pour les adultes elle est
très pratique aller portative il n'ya
rien dessus qui peut distraire aussi les
enfants et c'est en fait grâce à des
petits flashs lumineux qui sont presque
imperceptible eh bien ça va permettre de
corriger justement cette superposition
il faut le dire ça ne permet pas de se
débarrasser complètement évidemment est
de soigner la dyslexie mais ça permet au
moins de pouvoir soulager de pouvoir
aussi parce que ces enfants et ces
adultes d'ailleurs doivent compenser
tout au long de la journée c'est
extrêmement fatigant voilà et selon
leurs dernières études et bien cette
lampe développer donc pourrait avec une
orthophoniste c'est très important de le
dire pour être efficace pour environ 80%
des personnes dyslexiques merci beaucoup
julia siggers pour votre billet science
consacrée aujourd'hui est la dyslexie
merci à vous